- Hello everyone, I'm Ed McMahon and now--
- Here's Johnny.
- It's time for a clash of the kings,
or King as the case may be.
IT Chapter Two is heading
into theaters soon
and to honor everyone's
favorite googly-eyed clown,
we decided to celebrate his
creator, Mr. Stephen King.
On this show, celebrations
get competitive,
so we're pitting King's
best theatrically-released
horror film adaptations against each other
in a winner take all bracket style brawl.
Get your popcorn ready Georgie, pop, pop.
- Pop.
(laughing)
- Here's how it works.
We took the 16 highest-rated
Stephen King horror
movies on the tomatometer
and seeded them accordingly.
So, if you're a fan of Stephen
King's more cult classics
like a Dreamcatcher, a
Children of the Corn,
sorry, they're not showing up anywhere.
Kids, go out in the field and play.
From this bracket of 16,
we'll whittle it down
to eight and then four
and then two and finally we'll crown
the all time greatest
Steven King scary flick.
Friendly reminder,
although being in prison
or bullied by Kiefer Sutherland is scary,
King's drama adaptations
are not a part of this list.
So no Shawshank, no Stand By Me,
no environmentally conscious mile.
And if you're wondering,
was the original IT released in theaters,
I will simply answer with a polite no.
- Exactly.
- But, shout out to the OG Pennywise
who was played by the
legend, Mr. Tim Curry.
One plus one plus two plus one.
- Even if you are right,
that would be one plus
one plus two plus one,
not one plus two plus one plus one.
- The jump ball's in the air
and it's time for the sweet 16.
Let's run through these match-ups
and find out who's
advancing to the next round.
The top-seeded Carrie is going up
against the 16 seed, Silver Bullet.
Carrie was Stephen King's
first horror novel,
the one that did well enough
for him to quit teaching.
And the film was his first
big-screen adaptation.
This is why we have all those
other movies to talk about.
Thank you, C Money.
- No I just don't like ruffles--
- You don't like ruffles?
You don't have to get ruffles!
- Silver Bullet, on the other hand...
Remember that one?
Mysterious deaths start
happening in a sleepy town
so Corey Haim and his uncle
have to stop a werewolf.
Who plays his uncle?
Who else but Gary Busey.
- Ta-da!
- And, despite my affinity
for all things Busey
and my love of Coors Light,
Silver Bullet is being stopped
by the Kevlar known as Carrie.
Carrie advances.
- That's bullshit luck.
Bullshit luck!
- Next up we have
Creepshow versus Christine.
Creepshow was King's screenwriting debut
and directed by the horror
master himself, George Romero.
It played then and now as
a horror-comedy anthology
with an eclectic cast that
includes Hal Holbrook,
Ted Danson and Leslie Nielson.
I love it!
- Cringe and weird Kids.
- However, I would have
to say that Christine
is the better known property,
simply based on the fact that Christine
is a car that gets picked on
and develops a revenge-hungry
mind of its own.
In short, this movie can scare anyone
who's ever driven a car.
Any Plymouth owners out there? (pop)
Shout out to you.
Buckle up.
(tires screech)
The next battle is between
two more recent King movies,
IT from 2017 versus
Pet Sematary from 2019.
Both are reimaginings from
their original adaptations,
and while Pet Sematary
did have solid reviews,
IT was a world-wide phenomenon,
dominating the box office
and canceling clown
birthday party performances
at a record pace.
Pennywise gets the win.
(clown snarls)
(children scream)
We move on to The Shining
versus The Dark Half,
and to be clear, this is
The Shining from 1979,
not the TV movie starring
Steven Weber from Wings.
Underrated sitcom.
- You burned Helen's house to the ground.
(laughs)
- Oops. (chuckles)
- Speaking of underrated,
The Dark Half has a premise
some might say spawn from
Stephen King's own writer fears.
Timothy Hutton plays an author
whose pseudonym starts
actually killing people.
- Sorry, Rhett, it's a cutthroat business.
- And while we're on
the subject of authors,
how about that Jack Torrence?
Dedicated family man and
boy, does he work hard.
The Shining is the all-time classic
that inspired generations of horror lovers
and that's why The
Shining is gonna move on.
(piano music)
Speaking of hotels, our next
fracas is 1408 versus Cujo.
Now, Cujo is definitely the
more well-known property
and has a permanent place
in our cultural zeitgeist.
However, as the stepfather of a dog,
I don't want to perpetuate any media that
portrays dogs as anything
less than the angels they are.
1408 may be the lesser-known horror film
that features a hotel,
but the paranoia of
John Cusack's character
has a slow burn that doesn't let up.
1408 gets to stay another night.
- (whispers) You gotta be kidding me.
- The Dead Zone versus 1989's
Pet Sematary is up next.
And remember how I just defended dogs?
Yeah, I don't feel the
same way about cats,
especially if they're dead already.
I'm totally cool with
cats creeping up the joint
and the original Pet Sematary
had a massive effect
on me as an 8-year-old.
Why?
Because my aunt took me to see it
in the theater when I was but eight.
I don't know why she did it.
It still haunts me to this day.
Sorry, Chris Walken, Pet
Sematary gets to move on.
Man, we just can't escape pets.
Cat's Eye is taking on The Mist
and the former is another
anthology from King's mind
and directed, once
again, by George Romero.
Three stories all
featuring the same feline
running around, making
things uncomfortable,
and judging the humans.
Just like kitties do in real life.
(cat meows)
Meanwhile, The Mist is so creepy
and dripping with societal metaphors
that it deserves to advance.
You stick with that flick long enough
and the payoff features monsters
and it gets very, very depressing.
(man yells)
The Mist advances and any cat that was
watching this vid, has now turned it off.
Thanks for the click, Garfield.
Our last match up in this round features
Misery versus the 2013 remake of Carrie.
This was a good remake of Carrie
and it had plenty of blood,
but how in the world
would I let Misery lose
to a cockadoody remake?
Paul Sheldon finished his book,
he threw a snowball strike
and was on top of the world
until he wound up in a super fan's bed.
Eh.
Misery will have plenty of
company because it gets the win
and is moving on to the elite eight.
- He didn't get out of the cockadoody car!
- [Host] And now time for the elite eight.
Our first match up is
Carrie versus Christine.
A car that kills people is a fun idea
and gives all of us
Herbie the Love Bug fans
something to think about,
but Carrie has transcended
the horror genre
and become an iconic representation
of how scary being a teenager can be,
especially in that family.
It's more relatable and thus
infinitely more terrifying.
Plus, I'd hate to think that
all that pig's blood went to waste.
Carrie advances to the final four.
(kids laugh)
- The next match up will
cause a lot of comments.
How do I know this?
Am I Dionne Warwick?
No, but these two flicks
are all-time scary hits.
IT versus The Shining.
Wow!
IT was an international
money making juggernaut
that rebooted at the right time,
capitalizing on our
love of Stranger Things
and our fear of clowns.
It made $329 million domestically,
which more than doubles
The Shining's total.
Yes, I adjusted for inflation.
- Time to float.
- For a clown that only shows up once,
what, every 27 years, which makes it
all the more curious that
I'm picking The Shining.
- I'm not real enough for you?
- I know, I know.
Sometimes it just comes down
to which flick is scarier.
The Shining has more all-time horrific
images that stay with you.
The twins, the big wheel, the elevator,
the bartender, the bathtub.
Get out of the tub, lady!
You're starting to prune.
And plus, ugh, poor Shelley Duvall.
- Yeah.
- Both movies are hits,
both have sequels coming
out later this year,
but The Shining is
advancing to the next round.
(ice clinks against glass)
Next up is 1408 versus Pet Sematary.
This one is an easy call for me,
but let's tout 1408's
impressive stats first.
$237 million total at the box office
and it's 79% fresh on the tomato meter.
Meanwhile, Pet Sematary
made $167.4 million
at the box office and is
just below fresh at 52%.
However, 1408 is a creepy, psychological
horror exploration that we saw and went,
yeah okay it's pretty good.
Pet Sematary is everywhere.
We all know what it is, we're
born with that knowledge.
There's a place that you
do not bury anything.
(imitating Fred Gwynne)
Sometimes, dead is better.
- Sometimes, dead is better.
- Also, spoiler alert, no
one dies on screen in 1408.
It's just a wacky night in a hotel room.
Meanwhile, Pet Sematary has this.
- Never get out of bed again!
Never get out of bed again!
- I was only eight years old!
Eight!
Pet Sematary's going to the final four.
- I brought you something, mommy.
- Our last movie date match up
features The Mist versus Misery.
Yeah, I like The Mist
and it gets credit for being fresh at 72%
and having some impressive
monster-related deaths.
34 people eat it in this flick.
34!
Well done, fog spiders.
Problem is, The Mist is
running into a buzzsaw
and her name, Annie Wilkes.
- Oh, I hope I didn't wake you.
- Misery is certified fresh at 90%,
considered an all time
classic, won Academy Awards,
and even though it only
has two deaths in it,
we also see feet getting clubbed.
Eww.
Between that and Zelda,
I am limping out of this studio today.
Misery gets the win.
- The operation was called hobbling.
- You are looking live at the final four.
So the film that started it all, Carrie,
now faces its most daunting challenge yet,
The Overlook Hotel.
Most of us were a little
scared of prom anyway,
so Carrie had a leg up.
But as someone that
stays in a lot of hotels,
The Shining gets in your
head and never leaves.
Why does any hotel still have room 237?
Y'all don't have a 13th floor
but you're cool with the dead
zombie lady in the bathtub?
Get your priorities straight, hotels!
Signed, a Loyal Bonvoy Member.
Anyway, all due credit to the pair
of Academy Award nominated
performances in Carrie
from Sissy Spacek and Piper Laurie,
but The Shining holds
up as the scarier flick.
This is despite the fact that The Shining
not only earned zero Oscar nominations,
Shelley Duvall and Stanley Kubrick
each received a Razzy nomination.
Not appreciated in its own
time, or by the author,
but I'm here to give The Shining its due.
All work and no play makes Jack a dull boy
but Jack's movie is playing in the finals.
(man sings creepily)
And in the other final four matchup,
it's a real underdog story.
But you don't want to
play with these dogs.
Or these cats.
Or anything else buried in Pet Sematary.
- It's misspelled, but
that's what it says.
- This film is such a cool concept
and features some truly chilling moments,
both from events central to the plot--
- Don't let him go in the road, son!
- And from random back stories
put in just to give me nightmares.
I'm going to twist your spine.
(laughs evilly)
But Misery has two A-list actors
giving tremendous performances,
including the Oscar-winning
turn for Kathy Bates.
We cannot overstate how important
that win was for horror movies,
second only to comedies,
in terms of film genres
that simply don't get enough
credit come awards season.
Just ask Toni Colette, who I'm still upset
wasn't nominated for Hereditary.
The film builds suspense so well,
has some viscerally terrifying moments
and gave us a villain for all times.
- I don't want her spirit.
- If there's a Mount
Rushmore for movie villains,
it's gotta be the Wicked
Witch of the West,
Darth Vader, Annie Wilkes
and Chet from Weird Science.
- You're stewed, buttwad.
- Misery buries Pet Sematary
and moves on the the finals.
- I'm my number one fan.
- And now, we've arrived
at the championship game.
Steven King's all-time
theatrically-released
horror film adaptations,
it all comes down to
Misery versus The Shining.
In this corner, we have a crazed author
and his opponent is someone
who would probably love his books.
Jack versus Annie.
Snow versus, well, more snow.
(wind howls)
To determine my ultimate
Stephen King movie,
I'm looking beyond all
the box office accolades
and performances that
got these flicks here.
To earn the crown, I'm looking
into their all-time legacy.
Where do these films rank
in the pantheon of
all-mighty horror cinema?
Misery was perhaps King's
most prized possession,
or at least the one he was
most strict about optioning.
He only wanted Rob Reiner to make the film
and that was only after Reiner
did such a fantastic job
with another King story, Stand by Me.
Speaking of Rob Reiner,
Misery's success was a reaffirmation
that you didn't have to be
considered a horror director
to make a great scary flick.
Reiner was coming off rom-com
hits like When Harry Met Sally
and The Princess Bride
when he made Misery,
but if you wanna talk
about big-time directors
venturing into the world of
horror, enter Stanley Kubrick.
Despite the protests from King himself,
The Shining has become
a cultural touchstone
that resonates with
generations of movie lovers.
For example, how about
the extended sequence
in 2017's Ready Player One
that takes place in The Overlook Hotel.
It's just another reminder of
how truly scary The Shining is
and how horrifying hotels
can be at 3:00 a.m.
If you see a bartender in
the middle of the might,
in a hotel, it is a ghost.
Go back to your room.
- It is slow tonight, isn't it?
(laughs maniacally)
- Misery is an undisputed
classic scary movie.
It features unforgettable performances,
spine-tingling suspense
wrought by Rob Reiner,
and the film can claim
what few horror movies can,
Academy Awards.
Meanwhile, The Shining
has found its own place
in the pop culture lexicon,
and that legacy only
seems to grow stronger
with each passing year.
To be one of the top films
of both Stanley Kubrick
and Jack Nicholson's legendary
careers is no small feat.
And now, to declare my winner.
Quick sidebar to heighten the tension.
Barnes and Noble did a cool article
that ragged the King horror movies
in terms of faithfulness
to their source material.
Misery was the most faithful
and The Shining was number 13,
which makes it all the more nutty
that I'm proclaiming The
Shining as my winner!
(claps)
It's the scariest one to me.
I know not to go driving
during a blizzard on mountainous terrain
but to not stay at hotels?
Come on, I'm a comedian,
that's unavoidable.
Tickets at MarkEllisLive.com
The Shining takes the prize
and just like they do for March Madness,
cue the song One Shining Moment.
♪ You reached down inside ♪
- Anything you say, Lloyd.
Anything you say.
- The good news is, I'm
not gonna sing anymore.
The really good news,
is that all of this is just my opinion.
Stephen King certainly
doesn't agree with me.
How about you?
Now it is your turn to
vote for the all-time best
Stephen King horror film adaptation.
We'll post our bracket below.
All you have to do is leave a
comment below with your take.
What's the best?
What's the scariest?
Which movie do you wish
was in the Sweet 16?
Any Sleepwalker fans out there?
Salem's Lot?
Let us know right now.
Thanks for tuning in and remember kids,
if a jittery old lady made
you cookies then got naked,
she's probably a murderous clown.
Have a great day.
(upbeat music)